security forces have been deployed to
central Cairo after rare anti-government
protests broke out Friday evening in the
capital and other cities demonstrators
called on President Abdel Fattah al-sisi
to step down amid allegations of
widespread corruption say don't be
scared Sisi has to go the message from
hundreds of protesters in and around
Tyrus square in Cairo Egypt calling on
President Abdel Fattah el-sisi to step
down these demonstrations are a rarity
in today's Egypt sparked by appeals
shared on social media to take to the
streets in opposition to government
corruption and oppression
since el Sisi was elected he's
consolidated his power and enacted an
unprecedented crackdown imprisoning
thousands of political Islamists secular
opposition figures and popular bloggers
this is the first major protest against
el Sisi in which demonstrators have
defied a ban on public protest
[Music]
according to reports security forces
have been quick to disperse crowds with
tear gas 55 people have so far been
officially arrested but reports suggest
their initial momentum is not abating